dice che possiamo partire ti faccio io
in genere i ragazzi benvenuti che sono
video sono famiglie siamo ancora richard
ciao facciamo un'altra competizione
design cose serie cose molto serie
prodi diversa la data da oggi facciamo
una sorta di comparse che è successo per
questo ascoltare
cerchiamo di mettere a confronto le
nostre capacità tecniche capacità
catafratti di disegno su carta nel senso
che adesso noi sceglieremo delle cose
che voi ci avete consigliato nelle
storie e avremo un minuto of new do céu
mino per disegnarle fino sui fogli e
vedere chi si avvicina di più quindi ci
sarà un vincitore ci sarà un vincitore
si era detto io non l'ho detto non
scommetterei prime però scommettiamo
quanto scommettiamo che quello che
abbiamo nel portafoglio ma che fa cose
scommettiamo questa spiega allora prima
reference che ci avete consigliato
esalta allora pane partiamo con juan
fudge man viavai cosa ma poi passò poi
fatto non aveva speranze di fare un
pelato
mamma mia ragazzi nella sua gente se c'è
un pò la rete ma come possono cambiare
un po no non puoi come allora ma io
amico mio non saprei neanche dalla mia 4
secondi
[Musica]
il super mastellone americano ora e
homer si senti io non faccio commenti
sul tuo amato tantissimo
va bene e questo è salita sai come si
chiama ma allora facciamola si riprenda
lei
arriviamo alla fine che poi sarà il
pubblico a decidere chi ha vinto questo
qua il primo al secondo me nei disegni
migliore comunque tanti hanno chiamato
lascia il nome non posso fare aggregati
i due fantagenitori fantagenitori allora
i due fantagenitori a ecco ad esempio i
275 ci ho vissuto entro non saprei da
dove fare ma lui anch'io cielo visto un
sacco di volte ma disegniamo la nostra
rai ora venendo vai madonna la partenza
non è male incredibile cioè con po
schifo tutto il resto abbiamo ancora tre
secondi mentre cosmo non possiamo fare
gli menti della gente va bene allora io
io avevo si vede che io si vede che c'è
una pioggia
mandai così in effetti è vero si vede
che qua ci avevo più mente io che
com'era ma tu sei più bravo a disegnare
comunque sia vediamola così però è
perché guarda il mio piccolo vizio che
va la testa gigante il corpo
piccolissimo e quindi l'attesa però però
non lo so disegnare invece lavora
infatti io mi ricordavo che ci avevano
la testa gigante ma poi non essendo
sicuro ha disegnato comunque un delle
promozioni
ma chi è e team che mi stavo mangiando
l'altro vanta cosmo e cosmo però non
puoi non fa niente è un fantasy è
aumentato nella nuova season sword art
on line ha ricordato online persone
anche come iniziare sta andando in
senato non so da dove inizia e li faccio
vediamone i capelli non ho neanche io
c'è allora mi ricordo che aveva no era
un po di capelli era un po caduto
innanzitutto caduto il numero e
prestatori ok ma davvero non una persona
simpatica scrivete non so aveva un
mantello no due secondi un secondo 0 e
abbiamo una tecnica di verdi disegno
molto diversa non c'è io vedo molto più
il realismo e tu il realismo realismo
nuovo realismo è una nuova corrente è
un'antica mano al corrente nel senso che
una scuola gigante di ferro gigante di
ferro vice mamma mia che bello era il
genietto di ferro rai uno dei miei
cartoni animati preferiti manto è
vecchia quindi magari colmo di voi non
lo non lo ha visto mancando recuperare
la vista si dice iscrivere al canale
byte io non mi allora assolutamente come
aveva festa non me lo ricordo
mamma mia ragazza non aveva il naso
probabile non aveva il naso non aveva il
naso i fatti mi pare è fine
non va bene un piccione proprio le idee
allora allora se posso essere sincero
c'è un momento in cui le fiji incazza e
ci ha gli occhi
se cosi e questo questo però io ho
aggiunto particolare io l'ho fatto c'è
la testa pd è stato un errore
involontario
se vuoi ribaltare la situazione questo
amo meno era alessandro disegniamo
alessandro borghese per cortesia
spiderman avvia mai come come
l'incredibile sicuramente bravo questo
nostro che mi amino stupì trimstre una
dedizione ragazzi maledizione tutto il
tempo passato ora che sono stato
bravissimo a far l'occhio tre secondi
due secondi un secondo
[Musica]
la nomina delle leggo io l'ho fatto più
incazzato in effetti tu fino a qui non
era male eri molto più realistico se
guarda sembra anche bene è vero perché
ben è una specie di spider man è molto
arrabbiato come sta yuri chechi ragione
perché sono nato per gioco c'è un
moschettiere va bene sa cos'è questa
ragnatela correntista in aria prima si
sta attaccando salto tipo super mario
non ho guardato guarda qui ti faccio
sapere i miei complimenti grazie a vista
ma amatoriale quando per esempio il
disegno e blu però però non voglio
dirtelo io soltanto lasciarti una specie
di zona grigia no ti dico non riesco a
credere a quello che sto guardando sono
senza parole questo commento non fa
capire niente quindi sei senza parole
senza parole
adventure time l'ultimo disegno di oggi
ma caso adventure time
qui ci si gioca tutto è ricordiamo la
catena ricordiamo non mettiamo ci si
gioca qui renda lei e la sua dignità
la mia dignità e la mia andata via da un
po via ma non mi ricordo ma vende tanto
neanche di giuro non ho assolutamente mi
pare fosse così ma non sono anche tra
positivo i miei sembrano in stato di
ecstasy tutti i guai se non ci fosse un
domani ok comunale di okami stessa
fisionomia j per noi
non mi ricordo neanche come cavolo si
sta squagliando sì ho finito
va infine sul serio mi sembra meglio ma
non sto scherzando sono seriamente
sorpreso ma sembra già un petardo in
mano a sempre che appena lanciato un
razzo che volevo fare una spalla ma mi è
riuscita male troppo punta vera voluta
però la faccia a faccia ci sta anche
bene faccia si sta però guarda che cosa
sta facendo male sta squagliando j che
siccome non mi ricordavo come ho detto a
vedere questo lo facciamo proprio così
perché tanto non avevo altro modo sembra
appunto abbiamo finito questa sfida di
disegno oggi bella iscrivetevi ragazzi
facciamo un micro re.cup se sarete voi a
decidere chi ha figli e lei ha vinto il
peggio
by one pass man man
poi due fantagenitori io quello stop a
rendere questo tema fisica il più grande
di marco spider man
volevo e luglio al vento dai quali sono
andato da confronti complimenti molto
tratterò la tua dignità bene i soldi ai
romani e wi fi
spero che mi viene sia piaciuto io
lascio al mio amico riccardo la mia
dignità e noi ci diamo questo video
iscrivetevi al canale passate la
caricatura della camera e la così via
rione utile
quindi non riescono perché sono arrivati
maledizione noi ci vediamo nel prossimo
video non al telecomando di nuovo qui mi
chiudo con joyce bella ragazza
[Musica]